hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast in vivo imaging tool kit
advancing pre clinical and translational
science in molecular and orthopaedic
research at UCLA I'm Cristina jewel of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader focus on improving the health and
safety of people in the environment
their dedicated team of 8,000 employees
worldwide are passionate about providing
customers with an unmatched experience
as they help solve critical issues in
human and environmental health
PerkinElmer innovative detection imaging
informatics and service capabilities
combined with a deep market knowledge
and expertise help customers gain
greater insight into their science to
better protect our environment our food
supply and health of our families for
more information please visit www missed
a couple of important announcements this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speakers we
have two speakers for you today Jason
Lee PhD and Nick Bernthal MD speaking
first today will be dr. Lee dr. Lee
received his PhD in D MMP under dr. K
Ezra do at and his postdoctoral training
in molecular imaging at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center under dr.
vladimir ponomarev with his work focuses
on the development and integration of in
vivo
imaging assays to quantitive ly assess
the functional dynamics of health and
disease and to study associated
therapeutic intervention in preclinical
models I will now turn it over to dr.
Lee I thank you Christy this is Jason
and today's the presentation from my end
is going to be somewhat of an overview
of the types of preclinical imaging
modalities that are available but also
that are mainly used at the krump
Institute here at UCLA so I usually like
to start off with this slide which gives
an overview of the different type of
imaging modalities space that one can
assess imaging in general is considered
either anatomical or functional there's
also that the level of molecular imaging
which allows once you see at a much
lower or much higher resolution in terms
of by the biological activity so this
slide gives an overview of how this
imaging how different types of imaging
modalities are available and can span
this space from us understanding from
the genomic level proteomic level
metabolomic level all the way up to the
anatomy you can see that within that
range there's functional imaging which
not only allows one to see the presence
of certain types of receptors or enzymes
or whatnot but actually to be able to
monitor their function in real time
while there are multiple types of
imaging modalities are available it
doesn't necessarily mean that they are
both available in the preclinical
setting in small animals larger animals
and also available human there are some
caveats to how we can be translatable so
I'd like to present the slides give an
overview of what imaging modalities can
easily translate to the clinic or that
are they already available in the clinic
for the most part all of them can be
even though on this slide is shows that
certain ones like optical is not
necessarily translatable nowadays that's
not necessarily true you do have some
surgery for example that does implement
optical imaging and Nick burns all who's
going to be speaking next maybe Oh as
you get more insight into how that how
that translation works so this slide is
is something that i tend to present
because it seems to summarize quite a
bit of what it is that the krump is able
to do with the types of imaging
modalities that we are well versed in or
that we have available so you can see
that one it spans different types of
biological activity biological questions
and research using different types of
modalities here we mainly look at three
different types we have PET scanners CT
scanners and optical scanners and then
on the lower left corner you could also
see some high resolution metabolic acids
that we can perform it on going to that
a little bit later generally speaking
there are certain types of parameters
that one wants to consider when they're
looking at imaging modalities to
determine which one best fits their
research projects for the most part most
users would look into how sensitive are
these imaging modalities for detecting
the structures anatomy the activity or
function that they're looking for and
then also the space of spatial
resolution is it able to detect single
cells or are we looking at larger
Anatomy like different types of organs
and it's not one or the other is usually
one wants to look at both sensitivity
and resolution ideally of course you
want to have the highest resolution of
the highest sensitivity but based on
this chart one can see that it's not
necessarily available for all different
types of modalities there are pluses and
minuses for each one so the key is not
necessarily to to find the one with both
high sensitivity and high resolution
ideally that would be the case but the
key is really to find which one fits the
research question of interest and to
determine if sensitivity is more
important resolutions more important or
is there a compromise between the two
that one can select so
the ones that we tend to have here at
UCLA it does span everything that you
see here even in the clinic we have spec
scanners and PET scanners see TMR and an
optical in the preclinical setting of
the krump we focus mostly on pet CT and
optical imaging and then to a certain
degree we also collaborate with another
Center on campus for mr so generally
speaking we do have all these modalities
available to our users and this chart is
just another explanation of the
different type of parameters that one
would like to consider I put them into
the order of different types of
sensitivity and they're all relative to
mr so if we look at relative sensitivity
on the right-hand side mr is one and the
higher the number the more sensitive
some of these assays are and then we
also have the spatial and temporal
resolution those you have higher spatial
resolution when one wants to look at
anatomical structures because for the
most part those do not require
additional types of agents that you
injected or different types of detectors
and so for example mr and x-ray CT you
can one can see has some of the highest
special resolution even though here it
says 100 microns they actually can't
even go down to two sub micron level is
like 50 nanometers for example but
that's also relatively speaking
depending on certain types of
reconstruction methods or algorithms
that some of these scanners would use
this is another summary the last summary
slide that I have here for the different
types of imaging modalities for the most
part is to give a sense of how do i
select which I'm adapt imaging modality
for what type of questions or process or
experiments that I have so generally
speaking optical imaging tends to be the
most high throughput either when it's in
vitro or in vivo simply because of the
lack of complexity of it one just
detects light emitted from from the
cells of interest of the organs of
interest in terms of sensitivity pet
does have a slightly higher sensitivity
optical technically does have higher
sensitivity but because of caveat of
detecting light in general pet does have
higher sensitivity the last parameter
there is this potential clinical
translation even though here it kind of
mentions that pet is the most clinically
translatable and more not being so much
but that's not necessarily true per se
depending on the situation and for the
most part all three of these modalities
can be translatable to the clinic in one
form or another so go into how we do
imaging here at Crump this is just a
summary slide of all the imaging
modalities equipment that we offer at
the center in the upper left we have
three different types of PET scanners
the siemens indy on the siemens focus
but then now we also acquired just
recently the perkinelmer of genesis
genesis ate my group at mcd combined
system for us that's actually been one
of the more high-throughput instruments
that allow us to do many many studies
very quickly on the right hand side we
also have the Ibis Lumina from
perkinelmer and a CRI fluorescence
scanner so the fluorescent scanner is
simply for imaging animals at different
levels of wavelength or fluorescent
agents whereas with the artists Lumina
were capable of doing both fluorescence
and bioluminescence and I'll go into the
bioluminescence a little more in the
second on the bottom panels we have the
ellipsis automate
synthesizers that's actually related to
pet imaging where one has to synthesize
the radioisotopes necessarily for
measuring different types of biological
activity we have an in-house what we
call chrome cap micro-ct that was built
in-house for us to do relatively high
resolution small animal imaging and then
the bottom right to equipment or two
types of equipment is for ex vivo
analysis of some of these assays the
ammonite automated gamma counter allows
us to look at biodistribution on tissue
to tissue level and the macro micro
crash films allow us to do certain
athletes like autoradiography which i
would show a demonstration of that a
second as well and this is definitely
this light is definitely not a summary
of all the different types of
publications that we have done here at
crump is just giving a four examples of
how imaging can be used for functional
analysis us with as well as anatomical
here at the prompt in at UCLA the top
one is looking at different types of pet
tracers pet isotopes that were used to
look at different types of biology the
right-hand upper right-hand side is
looking at immunology trafficking cell
trafficking of the immune cells and the
bottom left is also looking at cell
trafficking of immune cells bed using it
using optical imaging and then the
bottom right is actually looking at
pharmacodynamics the ability of imaging
to allow one to see the effects of drugs
in real time so going to the first one
I'm going to split this into three
sections the first one is on optical
imaging mostly focusing on
bioluminescence imaging the idea is very
similar to fluorescence imaging so I
think it should be a which cover both so
just a general overview of
bioluminescence itself essentially a
user expresses a what's going to
reporter gene in this case if you look
on the left hand side called firefly
luciferase and the way light is produced
is fr Foley separate expression alone in
the cell doesn't produce any kind of
signal it is its interaction with a
substrate in this case
Luce different the interaction between
was different and firefly luciferase is
what creates a light emissions and
that's essentially what's being detected
by the CCD cameras for example the itis
lumen and I've mentioned earlier and so
with bioluminescence imaging it allows
one to look at these different types of
Lucifer aces and this panel is a good
summary of what type of Lucifer aces are
available in the research community I
also put a link at the bottom if anyone
is interested in purchasing acquiring
some of these plasmids that that have
these different reporter genes in there
the table here is mainly to summarize
that there are quite a bit of luciferase
is available and one can choose which
one based on the several parameters that
it has the most important of which is
probably the kinetics one can see that
it says glow kinetics and flash kinetics
the main difference between the two is
how long once the interaction occurs
between the substrate and the luciferase
how long the light stays present for the
camera to detect it generally speaking
firefly luciferase has been used quite a
bit because it undergoes what's called
glow kinetics and so the moment a
substrate is injected that signal stays
around on the order of minutes let's say
for example 10 to 15 to 20 minutes and
that makes it very easy for users to do
high-throughput studies and to quickly
go through several animals at a time
whereas the flash kinetics it generally
doesn't doesn't do high-throughput
simply because the moment this substrate
is injected the signal going through an
exponential decay and so acquisition of
that light needs to be done as soon as
possible and also very consistently from
day to day if one is doing longitudinal
imaging on on the same animal and the
right-hand panel of the right-hand peak
emissions is also important most people
tend to not worry so much about that
but wavelength emissions each of these
luciferase reactions do have different
wavelength emission patterns and
depending on how long wants to use it
one can take advantage of the different
emissions to do multispectral imaging
for example if you had two cell
populations in the same animal one can
be expressing a certain rapport with for
65 nanometer wavelength and another one
can express something at a much higher
wavelength and the scanners themselves
have spectral and mixing probability
properties that allowed you to actually
be able to detect both at the same time
of course that assumes that you also
inject both different types of
substrates as you venture separate them
as well so these are two parameters that
one tends to look at when doing optical
imaging light itself does get absorbed
through different tissues and different
media that's inside the body and is this
you can see that it's dependent on the
wavelength emissions as well while it
looks like the least absorption is
probably around the 700 nanometer range
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
the only wavelength of which one can
actually acquire data it simply means
that when assessing the results one is
to take that into account or is want to
try to optimize the sensitivity of your
your reporter similarly light like any
other way different wavelengths does get
scattered through the tissue and that is
also dependent on the wavelength the
higher the wavelength the less scattered
and with less scatter that means that
the the signal does get to the CCD
camera which which less interaction
through the tissue before and so
combining both absorption scattering
when one is studying in vivo imaging to
take these two into account I can really
help in optimizing the project
so this is just a summary slide of
different types of imaging that you can
do with optical imaging this is mostly
this is actually only bioluminescence
but fluorescence is very similar if
you're familiar with flow cytometry and
choosing different like types of
fluorescence agents it's the same thing
in vvill the only difference is now
you're imaging within a live animal and
so if these cells are expressing the
different types of luciferase is you can
actually look at trafficking patterns so
you can on a left-hand panel is actually
a study of immune cell trafficking over
time the top and bottom is this
differentiating between different types
of treatments at the animal under one
and the circles that are showing the
expression or the trafficking of the
t-cells to certain lymph nodes you can
also do lung metastases models and
localizing that to specific regions so
you can see it's very specific and very
high generally very high resolution for
you to actually see where the the organs
are there localizations of those organs
here you can clearly see that these are
two different lobes of the hardware
these cancer cells have metastasized to
and a lot of users tend to do
proliferation studies expressing rapport
genes in tumor cells implanting those
tumor cells and using imaging to watch
the growth of those tumors the presence
of a signal is also important because it
actually says that these cells are
functional they are expressing these
elusive races and generating these
proteins and so it's also good to look
at whether or not your tumor cells are
viable within the animal or any type of
cells that you're interested in the
other modality that we do here both by
itself and also in combination with
other imaging modalities like pet is is
high resolution micro CT CT basically
uses x-rays and in 360 degrees
projections to allow us to
look it has a three-dimensional
holographic image of the in this case
the animal's body the mouse's body and
these mice are relatively small I would
say they are probably a couple
centimeters and Mike couple centimeters
maybe two three centimeters and with but
you can really get high resolution
anatomical structures simply from
imaging using micro CT the biggest
difference between micro CT and mr both
of which can it allow you to look at an
anatomy is that mr is very good for soft
tissue whereas micro-ct is very good for
denser tissues so you can clearly see
with legacy TV the bone structure is it
is very apparent but if you look on the
this the middle panel but also the right
panel which has a much higher view view
of you you can inject contrast agents
that have different different x-ray
density effects and you can actually
look at the specific organs of interest
so in this case on the right hand side
you can actually see the spleen on the
left side of that animal because we
inject an iodine contrast so Christy if
you can pull up the media video of
mousehole body contrast CT
you
okay thank you can you also pull up the
mouse vascular micro-ct
you
thank you very much Chrissy and so I
hope you got a sense from looking at
those two videos what the capabilities
are at least be able to appreciate the
capabilities of imaging CT alone looking
at Anatomy alone there's quite a bit of
information that that you can get out of
just simply looking at structure there
are users for example that are
interested in looking at vascular
calcification of different tissues and
CT would be fantastic for that because
of that that level of density coming
from these cupcakes calcified regions
but also you can inject the contrast as
I mentioned and actually be able to to
get the vascular structures in the whole
animal all these imaging modalities are
done on whole body level so we simply
image for our scanners we image for
about two minutes and we were able to
get these kind of resolution and these
kind of food of views of the whole
animal so for micro CT we also combine
it with our pet imaging and I'll explain
to you in a second one pet imaging is to
allow us to look at both functional and
also localization of where these
functional signals are coming from and
micro CT allows us to localize that
based on Anatomy so it's the crop
Institute our bread and butter I would
say is is positron emission tomography
which is a PET imaging using radio
labeled tracers these tracers range from
from small molecules which are from
traditional pharmacology drugs of
interest biological molecules inside the
body for example Google's after MERS
peptides and also proteins and a lot of
which currently are focused on
antibodies mini bodies die bodies so the
biological space is is pretty large in
terms of what pet imaging can allow us
to see depending on the tracers that we
radio label so radio labeling simply
means adding in this case what you can
see on the small molecules and f-18
fluorine-18
isotope that emits gamma rays and by by
allowing us to to see these gamma rays
with these detectors were able to
actually see the by distribution of
these small part of these different
types of molecules and depending on the
molecules that you choose you can see
what's called functional imaging or you
can also see what's called reporter
imaging or localization of certain
proteins or receptors in the body in
real time so a good example that most
people are probably familiar with and
that is generally done in the clinic is
fdg imaging fdg is an analog of glucose
that has been radio labeled with the
f-18 isotope regulated on the left-hand
panel is an animal that we inject it
with fdg and underwent head CT imaging
so the color the color scale and the
color patterns that you see on that
image is actually coming from the fdg
itself and its biodistribution what what
is interesting is that because it's an
analog of glucose when you look at that
image of the pet image you're actually
looking at which tissues are highly
glycolytic which tissues are actually
metabolizing of that glucose or that
Google's analog with with high avidity
so you can see BF there suggested brown
fat and this animal happen to not be
under a warm condition and so the brown
that was highly like lytic highly active
to maintain the heating of the animal
itself the heart which is right below
the VF my four myocardium you can also
see that's also very avid for fdg and
the reason for that is that the heart
itself is a muscle that is taking up a
lot of glucose in order for it to
function and that lends us to look at
the next type of modality which is
complementary to the pet which we call
autoradiography essentially the same
thing as the PET imaging the only
difference is that this and
si so if you look at the great images
there that's the same animal that's been
injected with fdg but we do
autoradiography basically exposed slices
of these animals to film that sensitive
to radiation and that allows us to have
a much higher resolution of the spider
distributions of in this case the FD
tracer and I've zoomed into the heart
just to show you that the FDA know
really is coming from the myocardium
there are plenty of other tracers that
have been developed at UCLA one of the
investigators developed a probe called
fhc which is an analog of a nucleoside
tiny our nucleoside compound
deoxycytidine and because it's a
substrate for the kinase in the
nucleotide metabolism pathway its its
image its pet image suggests that it's
actually measuring in real time the
function of that pathway and what they
demonstrated is that indeed if you have
a ad so d ck is the end is the kinase
that's specific for FAC that is required
for have a CD to be metabolized in each
of these tissues and so they image it
with the desk a knockout mouse which
lacks that D CK enzyme and clearly it
demonstrates its specificity of the FFF
HD probe for imaging D CK dependent
nucleoside metabolism if you also look
at the DC a 12-time mouse you can you
can see that new cosine metabolism is
very high in immune organs the bone
marrow displaying the thymus and so this
suggests that this tracer can allow you
to measure the function of different
immune cells or the presence of
different in sales other function
but it's also useful for other
applications FAC allows you see a
function of themselves but it could also
allow you to to measure the
pharmacodynamics of drugs that target
these enzymes of interests so in this
case because FAC specific to the d ck
enzyme by developing a DC inhibitor and
using the fac probe you can actually
image in the animal the effects of the
drug the effects of inhibition of d ck
and so here is simply doing FAC imaging
across different time points pre and
post treatment of the D CK inhibitor and
you can clearly see that the disc
inhibitor has a very short therapeutic I
guess half life in the order of hours
and this is very useful to be able to to
determine what type of drugs and how
successful some of these drugs can be
and this can also be translated in
clinic that if this inhibitor was
clinically relevant patients can be
scanned with FAC after treatment to see
whether or not target was hit the the
other type of imaging tracers for pet
with the latakia me know pet and these
take advantage of different types of
antibodies mini body body structures
radio labeling them and injecting into
the animals to look at their targeting
of surface receptors surface antigens
this is just a summary slide to show the
of the different sizes of these proteins
and how they distribute through the body
I you can see from the graph themselves
that the smaller the protein the smaller
the these antibodies or anybody analyze
the faster they cleared of the body but
also shows that the better that they may
may bind to the surface antigens
and finally I'd like to end with with
imaging of immunotherapy which i think
is a very hot topic nowadays so these
will be good to kind of go over how
imaging especially PET imaging can be
integrated into immunotherapy this is
simply as a schematic of how adoptive
cell chance for immunotherapy words
essentially a donor could be the same
amount a donor that has antigen-specific
t lymphocytes against for example here
that kisa tumors of interest those cells
are cultured ex vivo and during that
because their culture and ex vivo one
can actually take advantage of that that
stage and introduce the reporter gene
and by introducing the reporting that
allows you to subsequently be able to
monitor the blood distribution of the
cells in vivo once they're injected into
into the animal into the patient and so
here's an example of applying optical
imaging in this case bioluminescence
imaging into an animal that underwent a
full treatment of adoptive t-cell
transfer you can monitor this animal
from the day after injection all the way
to when the population has expanded
throughout the body but not only that
you can also see the localization of
where these cells actually traffic to
whether another hitting target in this
case this mouse has a brain tumor and T
cells that are targeting antigen in
these brain tumors and you can clearly
see where those white arrows are that
indeed the T cells are active and that
they are targeting the tumor cells of
interest in the brain themselves but
additionally you also see that T cells
are developing in other regions of the
body and other mental brigands in
particular bone marrow and spleen
and earlier we mentioned using antibody
so because these T cells also express
surface receptor surface antigens see
dat pores we can also develop antibodies
that target each of these subpopulations
and use these antibodies as imaging
traces to detect them detecting cells in
vivo so Richard Tabari here has
developed a CD for specific immune
effete agent and a CD eight specific
amino pet agent and if you inject that
into your DSO transfer model as you can
actually detect subpopulations of T
cells in the body and this is summarizes
the different types of nuclear reporter
genes for pet imaging you can see that
depending on what these these adoptively
transferred cells are transduced with
you can use different tracers different
pet racers to detect these populations
of evil each one having their own caveat
in terms of sensitivity ability to
detect the cells in vvill there that are
enzymatic or receptor based or
transporter base but essentially any of
these should be able to allow you to
look at the cells in vivo once they get
a definitely transferred into the into
the animal and so a good example that is
here we're on day zero these cells were
these cells that express 34 jeans are
injected into the animals themselves
that was bearing a tumor and you can use
PET imaging reporter based test imaging
to look at the trafficking patterns of
these lymphocytes and whether or not
they hit to target in this case a
subcutaneous tumor but also you can see
that they localized two different lymph
nodes draining lymph nodes and you
cannot see it here but also the spleen
and I hope I gave you an overview here
of the different type of imaging
modalities that are available both here
at crump itself but also and many other
institutes and the main message is that
imaging is is an indispensable tool in
order to understand biology and
understanding biology within the animal
itself so with that I'd like to put it
back to Christie
thank you dr. Lee and our next speaker
is dr. Nick Bernthal dr. Bernthal is an
orthopedic oncologist who has been on
the UCLA faculty since 2013 he graduated
magna [ __ ] laude and phi beta kappa from
princeton university and received alpha
omega alpha honors from Cornell
University Medical School he did his
residency at UCLA in orthopedic surgery
and his fellowship in orthopaedic
research and musculoskeletal oncology at
UCLA and the Huntsman Cancer Institute
respectively his clinical interests are
bone and soft tissue tumors and his
laboratory is pioneering new implant
coatings to prevent surgical infections
I will now turn it over to dr. Bernthal
for his presentation dr. Brenda thanks
very much krisi and Jason thanks for the
great overview that was really terrific
so so Mike talks going to be a little
bit different I'm going to be a little
more specific into using some of these
preclinical models to answer some of the
questions we see as clinicians and and
that's one of the nice things as being a
clinician scientist so basically I just
want to start out I got very interested
in orthopedic implant infections and
using some of the tools that that dr.
Lee described earlier at the krump to
look into these and for those of you who
aren't in the orthopedic community this
is a huge issue both for our patients
and for our health system orthopedic
implant infections alone cost the united
states over 8 billion dollars of
additional health care spending every
year for me more personally I I'm an
orthopedic oncologist so I take care of
mostly young people with bone tumors and
and they're on chemotherapy at high risk
of infection and if they get their
implant infected they're often at risk
of losing both the limb and their life
from these infections so this is what
one of these implants that we put in
looks like taking a whole femur out and
replacing it with an endoprosthesis and
once it gets infected you can see you've
sort of you've lost the game here and
and you really can't help your patients
anymore
when we looked back in 2010-11 at animal
models of implant infection to answer
these questions we realize that most of
them were histology based they required
large numbers of animals you get one
data point from every animal so our
initial goal was just to develop a mouse
model that would allow us to
longitudinally track this and to
understand the phenomenon this is our
original design of our model and
basically it's a very simple surgical
model a que wires placed into the femur
and and then the joint is inoculated
with bioluminescent bacteria we
genetically engineered these mice so
that both their neutrophils and
macrophages in wavelength and that way
we can track with these ibis imaging
systems both the infection with
bioluminescence and the host immune
response with fluorescence in real time
these are pictures of the surgery we
open the knee joint we ream the knee
place the pin and then inoculate
close-up and that's a post-operative
radiograph in in H there and you can see
here these are the micro CT pictures and
you can see good placement of the
implant representing the model we do
have a media file here to show that if
it's easily accessible
if not we'll just go forward and we'll
get to the media files maybe at the end
so
you
thanks very much so we we look at these
models too with the ibis imaging system
we also used histology early on and
variable pressure scanning electron
microscopy and these are actually ways
to validate the imaging modality early
on and now that it's been so consistent
we've really stopped doing a lot of the
histologic endpoints but when you look
at this our initial model taught us a
lot and and you need five million colony
forming units to create an infection in
the skin and subcutaneous down at the at
this last barrel line here you create an
infection that goes out to ten days
without issue and we've tracked us out
to 90 days this stays consistent so with
just 500 bacteria you do create an
infection that can be tracked taking the
pins out and sonic aiding them doing
colony counts we saw that our r-squared
was almost one suggesting that the light
did correlate very closely with
bacterial counts and and then we started
looking at the host response and you can
see over on this right panel the bottom
line is an uninfected mouse you see
there's an immune response here down on
this bottom curve to the infection but
it's down to baseline by day five
whereas in an infected Mouse it stays up
because this infection is is recruiting
neutrophils with the post-operative
inflammation being increased and that
leads to the clinical problem which I'll
show in a minute early histology showed
neutrophil recruitment in an infected
Mouse very little in an uninfected mouse
and then variable pressure scanning
electron microscopy showed us biofilm
formation on infected pins whereas you
see sheet metal on the uninfected pins
that are clean no bacteria is formed on
them we use the quantum FX to look at
the cross-sectional analysis and these
were really beautiful images that helped
us understand the phenomenon if you look
on the Left panel where it's staph
aureus infected implants you see these
little pins indicate I excuse me these
little pits indicated by the red arrows
this is osteo lysis this is
our patients complain of if the implant
is infected it's honestly the problem
for the patient is that it induces an
osteoclast across s of eating bone away
and the implant bone interface starts to
break down then you have a loose implant
you can imagine walking around on an
implant that's rattling along inside
your bone is not a comfortable feeling
so we overlay everything here with these
bioluminescence and the micro CT and you
can see in this media clip exactly what
this looks like
you
great thanks very much so we were going
to and then we've developed this with
multiple models and looking into the
spine we as surgeons every surgeon
thinks they're very important and
special and so the spine guy said hey
make us a model and the knee guys wanted
their specific model and everyone wants
their model and so we decided to make a
spine model here and I incorrectly
thought this wouldn't add much to our
understanding since I've realized that
the anatomic location is really critical
and I'll show a bit of that later but
same idea surgical approach and then
inoculate with bioluminescent bacteria
and here with this model you can see
surgical technique in these pictures
same as before post-operative imaging
this is just a basic x-ray image and and
then we look at the bioluminescence and
we can track this this one's out to 35
days you see an infection at wanting to
just 10 bacteria excuse me 100 bacteria
are clearing whereas a thousand bacteria
are up and creating a creating a chronic
infection 23 and one for both stayed
chronic out to 35 days but when t4
showed skin breakdown so we selected the
one III dose of this Z nogen 36 so it's
Xen 36 strain of Staph aureus again CF
use and here's that fluorescence
tracking the neutrophils and infected
Mouse it stays high control it goes down
so I just want to spend five minutes
here showing you some of the
applications and some of this is
preliminary data some of it is published
data but if you look at some of the
questions these models answer for us so
when we get our implants infected we
always debate with our infectious
disease colleagues what antibiotic do we
treat these patients with so we decided
our model could answer this we do the
mouth surgery and inoculate the animals
and then we try to very common protocols
vancomycin alone or vancomycin plus
rifampin as well as some controls we
gave them IV antibiotics for seven days
and then we watch the infection
so if you look here at date seven I so
I'm going to get an arrow for you at day
seven here we start giving the IV
antibiotics and you see the combined
group vancomycin plus rifampin goes
dramatically down and if you use the
histology based assay you'd say this is
the right answer you'd be done at this
time point you'd feel really good about
your answer but the story gets a little
more complicated when you start
following these things out
longitudinally by day 21 both the bank
of meissen group and the control group
start to come down so the immune system
alone is starting to clean up this
infection vancomycin in the combined
group both to have fairly equivalent
results follow it out to 35 days and you
see that there's another bounce here
that you've cleaned out the soft-tissue
infection but you're getting an above
baseline signal at the spine regardless
of which group you use here and that's
the biofilm that's the part of the
bacterial infection on the implant
that's not clearing irrespective of your
treatment dose when we take the pins out
and culture them sonic 8 and culture we
get almost the identical number of CF us
off the implant whether we treat it or
didn't treat and this has profound
implication mean this really validates
our idea that the metal has to come out
if it gets infected because no matter
what we treat it with we end up with
that biofilm formation on the pin we
work a lot on implant coatings we've
designed a smart antimicrobial implant
coating that recognizes bacteria and
aleut out antibiotic in the face of a
bacterial trigger it uses a pH trigger
caused by the bacteria to release
antibiotics when it's challenged this is
my collaborator touch on asegura who
really did the bulk of the work on on
this design and and if you look here
here's what the pins look like here's
all in vitro testing classic in vitro
testing and then assing it against a
more acidic environment and and you see
that it dumps out antibiotic against an
acidic environment here with the pH
change if you if you then look now the
power is let's go back to the model and
see if it works so a coded pin in blue
up top show
that same curve we've seen all along
that's an infection the immune system
kicks in around base 7 and brings it
down but it stays well above baseline
going out to 42 days whereas if you have
the peg coding with the antibiotic and
at the tikka cyclin or vancomycin you're
down below baseline detection the colony
forming units validate this that the
coding seems to really work to protect
the implant and x-rays for us
orthopedist we like to see the clinical
problem and you see up top with no
antibiotic and if you get what's called
osteo lysis here and this is a
completely loose pin in the femoral
canal whereas in the other two that have
antibiotic in them you don't have you
don't have any loosening novel
antimicrobials were starting to work in
this field and and develop novel
antimicrobials gerard wang and andre
Casco or two collaborators who work on
taking antibiotics and giving them an
antimicrobial effect this is really a
very nice chemistry that they work on
here and you can see they take
tobramycin a very common antibiotic we
use and adding a group here a functional
group here to the end they make what's
called Pento bruh and in vitro testing
shows that it has great efficacy against
staph aureus and p ack knees two of the
bugs we see commonly so we've added that
into our coding now and our testing that
in the animal model to see using the
animal model as that assay to see how
successful this will be for our patients
finally I just want to show how we can
use this these imaging modalities to
look at the to look at the host and if
we flip the script here and start
looking at the host as surgeons we
oftentimes try and talk our patients
into quit smoking and lose weight and
control their diabetes we don't have
very much success at it so one of the
ideas we had was to look at giving a
boost of 25 vitamin D prior to surgery
as we know this is an immune modulator
through this catalyst sidon pathway and
here's some of the previous data
published data looking at this 25 d
driven immunity
but for us we wanted to ask a really
simple question can we prime the host
immune system for surgery and so we
developed a protocol that took lysozyme
egfp mice these are those that have the
neutrophils that are fluorescent we made
one group vitamin D sufficient normal
vitamin D levels two groups or vitamin D
deficient and then one group gotta
rescue dose of vitamin D just prior to
surgery when we look at this we saw
really first we drew blood levels to
make sure we were in fact depleting them
the deficient group stayed deficient
throughout the 14 days of the experiment
the sufficient group was sufficient
throughout and the rescue group did in
fact get rescued and if you look here
these are profound results with a single
dose of 25 d prior to surgery our rescue
group matched our sufficient group we
saw a logarithmic difference
statistically significant and this is
about a five times different and
infection in deficient and sufficient
mice with deficient mice having higher
infection burden and this is rescue abul
which just has such profound of
implications for our patients if we can
give them a single dose of vitamin D a
well-tolerated fda-approved vitamin
prior to surgery if we can really cut
infection rates this dramatically this
is maybe an easy solution to make a real
dent and a huge problem we do the CF use
and we saw matching again far fewer
bacteria when we had sufficient or
rescue mice that had vitamin D levels up
to normal and you see again the
fluorescence the neutrophils here the
deficient mice have far greater
neutrophil influx suggesting that this
vitamin D effect is not much is not
driven through the neutrophils but
rather when you look here and you do a
monocyte or macrophage assay you see the
deficient group was unable to muster the
same macrophage response so we're
working on this pathway suggestive of a
macrophage driven response we have two
parallel trials going on now in both
mouse and human patients and you see how
quickly you can translate these results
into into the clinic the last thing I
just want to show quickly is some tools
of intra-operative imaging
and and some of our collaborators and
the Netherlands have published this data
that shows using an iv injection of a
fluorescent probe you can potentially
tag bacterial cells in vivo if we could
do this and our bioluminescence would
you be used as the control if the
fluorescence matches the bioluminescence
suddenly now we could see the bacteria
in the operating room in our patients so
what we do currently is take out
everything every bit of metal someone
has if it's if we assume an infection
everything comes out this is a disaster
for our patients if we could actually
see the bacteria and what parts of the
implants were infected we could replace
just the infected part we could
potentially clean it and reimage and see
if we actually got the bacteria off so
so this is all a tool that I think is
coming down the pipeline you can see
here with a bank 800 probe and this is a
fluorescent probe in the middle it
matches our bioluminescence control at
six hours suggesting that we can in fact
see the bacteria where is it 24 hours
the fluorescence is gone and just
conceptually just conceptually it the
idea here is that bioluminescence
bacteria are genetically engineered
bacteria so they're great for study but
not for our patients if you had a
fluorescent probe that tags actual in
vivo bacteria we could use this probe in
our patients who don't have
bioluminescent bacteria but have
naturally occurring bacteria here are
some more images and a mouse that had no
bioluminescence here suggesting no
bacteria we had absent we had no
fluorescent signal as well so this is
really promising and coming down the
pipeline we've opened the skin and
opened the muscle and imaging in real
time lets us continue to see the
bacteria as we try and clean it so I
know I went through this pretty quickly
but I just want to make the point of of
that I do think we can decrease
infections this is a huge clinical
problem for our patients for our health
system and that using these model
systems as a fast screen we really can
decide what tools what coatings work
what vitamin manipulations work
what antibiotics work and and this is
the way we can translate these things
into the clinic and an efficient rate
without using histology thanks very much
here's some of the funding and a lot of
people to thank for all this work thank
you so much dr. Bernthal now before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and if we don't get to your question
we will answer those via email after the
presentation now our first question is
for dr. Bernthal desperate thought what
are the severe outcomes from a chronic
infection caused by an implant so yeah
that severe sorry can you just repeat
what are the severe outcome correct from
a chronic infection caused by anything
yes so so when an implant gets infected
what happens is the bacteria forms a
biofilm on the implant and and sets up
shop and we really don't think it's
treatable so what happens to the patient
then is over time it recruits
inflammation and these osteoclasts which
are the host cells that eat bone they
come in and they they start to eat away
the bone around the implant which some
of those axial pictures on the CT scan
showed and then the implant becomes
loose and when the implant becomes loose
it starts to become painful so that's
the mechanical symptom is just pain and
an inability to bear weight so a lot of
these implants are what someone's
walking on a knee replacement or a hip
replacement and they become loose and
painful but systemically these also
become night is's of systemic infections
so for my patients who are oncology
patients with implants these these
infections can often be very much
life-threatening and patients start to
get systemic infections which which can
absolutely be devastating thank you dr.
burns all I actually have another
question for you do specific models for
each orthopedic proceed
need to be established or is one model
of an implant in bone sufficiently
representative so I this is this was a
question that I was absolutely wrong on
when I had when we may or her first
model I sort of said alright we've got
an implant in bone model this should be
sufficient but what we found is the host
environment is totally different so in
the spine where you have a lot of
muscles surrounding the implant you you
actually get a much more robust immune
response as opposed to the knee that's
synovium is surrounding the knee joint
and and neutrophil influx is a lot less
so implants coatings antibiotics all of
them really do behave far differently in
different in atomic locations so I've
become much more of a believer that that
you need to model the specific test
question you're worried about for your
patience dr. Bryce all have you looked
at any knockout mice to better
understand pathways of host response
yeah we have we've we've used this a lot
night I didn't show that data because of
time but we've knocked out aya one
pathways and toll pathways and really
gotten a good sense of at least big
picture what what the host response is
to infection because really the
fundamental question as good as we think
we are as surgeons in keeping a sterile
environment there's bacteria in the
operating room and and when we think
about the fact that if 99 if we talk
about the one percent of patients who
get these major infections 99% didn't
get the infection so there's something
the host response is doing so these
pathways and knockout mice are are
really a powerful tool thank you very
much dr. Bernthal now next question is
for dr. Lee definitely what instrument
parameters let's see what instrument
parameters can i adjust to to increase
the sensitivity of detection in
Luciferian imaging using luminous 3 will
it increase the dosage of the severan
increase the sensitivity of detection
this is question number so the luciferin
itself the concept of the optical
imaging is that the recipient is already
injected at base a sufficiently high
level to saturate the system so
increasing the luciferin dosing may
provide a little bit of increase in
signal but generally it should not do
too much what you can do is actually on
the software itself there are three
parameters that can be adjusted one is
the exposure time the amount of time
that the camera is left open to acquire
the photons are being admitted to the
camera the longer you exposes the more
signal that you get and the better
signal to background that you should be
getting another the other two which are
generally less manipulated or the the
f-stop which defines how large the
opening of the lens is to acquire that
data the smaller the opening the less
thing or you're requiring so if you
leave it wide open then you're capturing
as much signal as possible of course the
smaller the opening the better the
resolution is because you're actually
now doing somewhat of a pinhole imaging
and then the last one is what's called a
helical binning and that's just how the
pixels are combined together to give you
higher sensitivity in a certain region
of you dr. Lee what kind of contrast
agents can you inject in high resolution
micro-ct so micro CT has there's many
different types of chemical compounds
that you can inject generally speaking
iodine based contrast and gold
nanoparticles are some of the main ones
that are being sold commercially
relatively inexpensive iodine seems to
work really well so the image are the
video that was shown earlier for
vascular CT imaging to look at the the
vasculature of circulation system that
was using a compound called Omni pack
and depending on how you injected that
would define how well that contrast
works so for that image to get the high
contrast for the vascular bed because
these contrast will by distributing
clear out of the system very quickly you
would want to do something like a CT
imaging during the infusion of that
contrast if so many great questions
coming in let's see it lets dr. Lee what
was the x-ray dosage used for the mouse
vasculature CT image so the the scanner
that we have is relatively low in terms
of a dosage radioactive dosage I think
it was it's determined to be about let's
see a 40 to 50 milligrams so relatively
low what is the largest animal species
with which you have experience in which
anesthesia agent do you use most
frequently so the traditionally nowadays
it's using the anesthesia is called
isoflurane mix it's about the two
percent that we use for mice and
sometimes rats mixed in oxygen or air so
generally speaking most Institute's
nowadays either use either flooring
through the paper rising system or you
can also do injectable anesthetic here's
a great cuffs are in the second bar the
question respective apples so most of
what we do is in mice a lot of our
scanners here are able to handle mice
rats but also they have been used
because of the large bore size of the
imaging scanner we could also do or
there have been done primates but I
personally do not do primates myself we
do mostly in whites and reds we have an
audience member who submitted questions
saying I am an imaging intracranial
tumors after implant implantation well
the skin glue on the mouth head affect
the Luciferian imaging accuracy so
potentially anything that interferes
between that has an interface between
where the signal is coming from and the
camera itself potentially can interfere
with the signal some glues should not
have any effect or not some dramatic
effect on the signal but that is
something that you would need to
actually assess one thing you can do is
simply feed some cells in a plate and
then image that using the
bioluminescence imaging or fluorescence
depending what you're looking at and
then maybe put a layer of glue on top
and see if that same signal has
diminished simply because of the
presence of the glue just validate how
much attenuate the signal especially
with Spenny imaging modalities how does
one select the imaging modality of
choice so that it actually comes down to
what is the basic research question
that's trying to be addressed using
these in vivo models I mentioned that
there's different types of imaging
modalities and each one offers different
types of information functional imaging
is if you're interested in looking at at
what happens to a cell is what is the
biologic activity at that cell during
the imaging process so we shows fdg and
using the fdg pet imaging we're able to
actually see the glycolytic metabolism
glycolysis in the animal tissues and the
tumors or cells of interest if you're
interested in looking at the structures
or for example if you want to look at
how different layers of fat or being
affected by treatment then you can
actually use something as simple as
anatomical CT imaging and analyzing the
different layers so it really comes down
to the question of interest and each
imaging modality or multiple imaging
modalities may be able to answer the
same question or complement each other
thank you dr. Lee we have great
questions coming in but I believe this
is all we have time for will you have
one question left using the lumina three
can you image both the tumor as well as
the trafficking of the immune cells cd8
simultaneously using two bioluminescent
signals fixed quick answer to that is
absolutely yes if you if you want to
look at two different populations at the
same time there's multiple ways of doing
that simply you do need to express to
different reporters reporter genes so
for example you could do a firefly
luciferase and a renilla luciferase the
way that works is that each with
separate interact with a different
substrate so if that substrate is not
present then owned that luciferase
should not to commit any signal even
though that protein is being expressed
so with Firefly let's say Firefly for
the tumor and renilla for the immune
cells
you can inject this different wow if you
see that back you can inject the the
renilla substrate coastal n tourism
which undergoes flash kinetics and that
allows you actually see the immune cells
very relatively quickly and because he
undergoes flash kinetics that signal
dissipate in the order of maybe even an
hour two hours and then you can inject
it was different and be able to see the
tumor population so alternatively what
you can do is do what's called spectral
on mixing which is that each of these
different luminous if races emit light
at different wavelengths so you could
acquire the data at the same time and
then spectrally post-acquisition unmix
those two signals based on wavelength
thank you dr. Lee I would also like to
thank dr. Bernthal for his presentation
as well dr. Lee would you like to leave
us with any final comments for the
audience no I'd like to thank everyone
for attending and hopefully it was an
informative session for everybody and
also if you can push out the link for
the second link that we have there to
the audience that's our website for our
Institute and I think it offers enough
information about what we discussed
today but also there's a link there for
some applications that you can review
what types of publications and research
people have done with different types of
imaging modalities that are available
that we discussed today thank you again
dr. Jason Lee and dr. Nick burns all I
would also like to thank our sponsor
perkinelmer for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June first 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
so much for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye